quando me chamaram pra falar sobre o
futuro da saúde
você vê as coisas que eu fiz foi colocar
isso no google
as imagens que apareceram deixado até
pressionada bonitas hologramas quatro
hospitais mega modernos é que no começo
a gente chegar e eu continuei falando e
pesquisando eu acho uma pesquisa do
economista que entrevistou 400
profissionais da área da saúde e validou
isso com donos de grandes empresas
multinacionais se os que trabalhavam na
área e pra eles o que era hospital
futuro da saúde nos próximos cinco anos
aparecendo coisas como a análise do
genoma realidade virtual nos próximos 25
que mais aparecer por exemplo é desenho
genético de bebês com até um pouco
estranho mas continua olhando e eu acho
que fiquei curioso
será que de fato é isso que está
pesquisando será que é isso que vem
procurando enquanto por exemplo áfrica
do sul no brasil ano passado chegava 900
mil pessoas para cirurgia eletiva ontem
que o rmg que em 2015 aquela três
minutos mais duas pessoas morreram em
hospitais por falhas que poderiam ser
evitadas
eu vou fazer um recorte para uma área
específica que a área que ouviu todo dia
quero da saúde visual do mundo 680
milhões de pessoas precisam de oxi não
podem pagar por um exemplo quem usa oxi
pode ser a favor
quem não usa eu ajudo
isso aqui é uma barraca vista com 5
graus de miopia pode colocar de novo
essa aqui é a mesma vaca 6 5 graus de
miopia e esse é o caso do saibam que
morava no malauí
o malawi dependendo do índice que você
usar é o primeiro o terceiro país mais
pobre do mundo
ele morava no interior do malauí era
agricultor
ele não sabia sequer que óculos existia
essa tecnologia tão inovadora tomou
existia ele ea gente deu seu primeiro
par de óculos mas duas semanas depois
voltou à casa dele ele estava usando
óculos porque saiu porque você não usa
óculos
ele explicou hoje à noite pela para o
marketing que estava lá que ele fazia a
colheita e pós colheita em 12 meses
depois estava dez meses
a comida acabava e até dois meses de
fome e ele soube usar o óculos para
acolher imagina sem os 10 por cento mais
eficiente
ele teria um mês a menos de fome
o negócio tão simples que é um par de
óculos e por isso o técnico
o alemão que é o marketing foi ele que
conheceu o saimon eles uma garagem
erlangen ficar uma hora de treino
rosberg na alemanha e começou a
desenvolver uma solução para esse
problema
eu quero criar um outro a tecnologia
social acessível para todo mundo e com
três materiais
um aço que dobrava dobrava dobrava
cobrava mais brava e com o plástico o
alérgico e com duas lentes de
policarbonato
ele conseguiu criar um óculos mais rico
do mundo que é um óculos que não quebra
e custa nos países momento de dois a
três dias para o mesmo local
e foi com ela a faculdade ainda eu
cursei simultaneamente três cursos
graduação eu fiz direito na usp
a economia é de um jogo ruim ter que
conhecer a tecnologia que já mudou a
vida de 100 mil pessoas no mundo inteiro
eu pude estudar porque muita gente me
ajudou 20 petróleo do rio teve bolsa e
eu juntei grupo de amigos a gente queria
retribuir à sociedade um pouco do que eu
recebi
enfim nós aqui no brasil em maio de 2014
na verdade hoje e 12 de maio faz exatos
quatro anos quem produzir o primeiro
óleo do brasil
a gente viu que um ou outro problema mas
estava nada é só esse óculos por exemplo
a saúde no caso que trabalhavam
tecnologia é acessível a todo mundo
hoje 85% dos municípios do brasil
no texto o lojista ou seja oito ou nove
em cada dez municípios não têm um médico
oftalmologista atuando freqüentemente
esse aqui o mapa que mostra regiões
a vermelha onde está carente a verde
está bom vai centrar nos estados mesmo
exemplo amazonas já que o censo
brasileiro de oftalmologia 2014 tem 62
municípios só cinco deles têm oftalmo
sendo que quatro deles tem um eo quinto
em manaus
se você tirar manaus da conta você tem
um hospital para 450
seis mil pessoas entrando estado fora
desafio logístico
aqui eu cuido bem diferente fazer
gráfico porque o cb ó colocará branca
hoje não tem médico área verde onde está
ruim
o vermelho está bom santa catarina está
totalmente desenvolvido tem 8% dos
municípios com o médico ele construiu
uma unidade móvel que consegue levar
saúde visual para regiões mais carentes
a evoluir para consolidar dentro de uma
mala
mas até poder ser mais eficiente por
exemplo como telemedicina
o governo do rio grande do sul até usado
no passado eles usam uma tecnologia pela
tele medicina oftalmológica para hoje
precisava este uma meta de reduzir em
40% a fila do sus no estado que está
desenvolvido em seis meses
infelizmente o nosso conselho de
medicina foram míopes e barrar a
inovação mas a sad beijo assim a gente
continuar trabalhando até hoje com essas
duas tecnologias tem consultório móvel
ea tecnologia desse ocs acessível haja
uma visão para 25 mil pessoas no brasil
em mais de 20 estados e mais de vinte e
duas pessoas receberam a primeira
consulta oftalmológica
vou dar um exemplo é que a rafaela na
semana passada estava em jaboatão dos
guararapes na grande recife até 12 meio
e 15 graus de miopia e usavam óculos fio
de nylon que uma lei tinha caído ea
outra da empresa com durex seu primeiro
par de óculos
roseane era mãe de dois filhos china 28
e 24 e meio ela três anos sem óculos
qualquer coisa uma criança com esse grau
quando perguntaram qual é a visão para o
futuro da saúde
claro que eu quero ver na tecnologia
claro que se eu ficar doente e graça
tratado no melhor hospital do mundo
mas antes disso eu quero que a sociedade
as empresas os governos e os indivíduos
como a gente passa de ser bi ups para as
milhões de pessoas que precisam ter o
básico e ainda não tem
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]